"
>> THIS IS CNN BREAKING NEWS.
>> AND LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO THE
BREAKING NEWS IN THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CAPITOL
INSURRECTION.
NEW SUBPOENAS TARGETING ALLIES
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHITNEY IS WORKING WITH STORY
FOR US.
THE TARGETS OF THESE SUBPOENAS
INCLUDE SOME HIGH PROFILE NAMES.
WE'VE SEEN THESE NAMES BEFORE.
THEY'VE BEEN IN TROUBLE BEFORE.
>> THESE ARE NAMES WE'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALEX JONES,
EXCUSE ME, YEAH, ALEX JONES AND
ROGER STONE.
FORGIVE ME.
THEY ARE TWO PEOPLE AT THE VERY
CENTER OF THESE STOP THE STEAL
RALLIES.
THOSE ARE THE TWO MOST
WELL-KNOWN NAMES IN THIS LIST OF
SUBPOENAS WHICH INCLUDES DUSTIN
STOCKTON, JENNIFER LAWRENCE AND
TAYLOR BUDOWICH.
THESE INDICATE THEY'RE REALLY
GOING FOR THE PEOPLE AT THE
CENTER OF THE TOP THE STEAL
MOMENT AND INVOLVED IN THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE RALLIES THAT
PROCEEDED THE RIOT.
THE SUBPOENA FOR JONES NOTES HE
WAS DENIED A SPEAKING ROLE AT A
RALLY ON JANUARY 6, BUT
INDICATES THE WHITE HOUSE EITHER
TOLD OR ASKED HIM TO LEAVE THE
MARCH TO THE CAPITOL FROM THE
ELLIPSE TO THE CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6th AFTER THAT RALLY.
THE SUBPOENA QUOTES ALSO FROM
JONES' OWN REMARKS IN DECEMBER
WHICH HE SAID, QUOTE, FINALLY
TRUMP HAS DONE THE RIGHT THING.
HE IS NOW CALLING ON WE THE
PEOPLE TO TAKE ACTION AND SHOW
OUR NUMBERS.
THE TIME FOR ACTION IS NOW.
WHERE WERE YOU WHEN HISTORY
CALLED?
ROGER STONE'S SUBPOENA POINTS
OUT HE PROMOTED HIS APPEARANCE
AT THE STOP THE STEAL RALLY AND
ASKED FOR DONATORS TO PAY.
WHILE IN D.C., HE REPORTICEDLY
USED MEMBER OF THE OATH KEEPERS
AS SECURITY GUARDS, SEVERAL OF
WHOM WERE INVOLVED IN THE ATTACK
ON THE CAPITOL AND AT LEAST ONE
OF THOSE PEOPLE HAS BEEN
INDICTED.
THE STONE SUBPOENA POINTS OUT
THAT HE WAS ALSO INVITED TO LEAD
A MARCH TO THE CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6th, BUT HE ENDED UP NOT
GOING TO THE RALLY ON JANUARY
6th AND DID NOT LEAD A MARCH
FROM THE ELLIPSE TO THE CAPITOL
THAT DAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THEY'RE EXPANDING THE NET.
WIDENING THE NET.
AND I THINK WHAT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS IS YES, WE RECOGNIZE
THESE BIG NAMES, BUT THESE
LESSER KNOWN INDIVIDUALS,
THEY'RE THE ONES WE'RE TOLD BY
OUR SOURCES COOPERATING WITH
THIS INVESTIGATION PROVIDING
INFORMATION.
>> RIGHT.
WHAT'S BECOME CLEAR IS THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS DOING TWO THINGS.
GOING FOR THE BIG FISH, BUT ALSO
TRYING TO SQUEEZE LESSER PEOPLE
WHO KNOW A LOT WHO MAY NOT HAVE
THE MEANS OF A STEVE BANNON TO
SHORE UP THEIR DEFENSE.
DUSTIN STOCKTON'S DEFENSE IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE IT POINTS
OUT HE WAS IN DIRECT CONTACT
WITH MARK MEADOWS AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THE MEADOWS PART IS SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE WE KNOW MEADOWS IS NOT
COOPERATING WITH THE COMMITTEE
IN THE WAY THEY WANT, SO IF THE
COMMITTEE CAN GET OTHER PEOPLE
IN HIS CIRCLE, THAT GIVES THEM,
TAKES A LITTLE PRESSURE OFF THE
COMMITTEE TO ACTUALLY GET
MEADOWS, BUT IT ALSO MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR HIM TO WIGGLE
OUT OF POINTED, INFORMED
QUESTIONS.
>> HE MAY WANT TO COOPERATE.
THANK YOU.
>>> MORE ON THE BREAKING NEWS
WITH JEFFREY TOOBIN.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY CNN LEGAL
AND NATIONAL SECURITY ANALYST.
THANK YOU, BOTH OF YOU, SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US.
JEFFREY, LET ME START WITH YOU
FIRST.
HOW IMPORTANT ARE THESE FIVE
INDIVIDUALS?
ROGER STONE, HE'S ALREADY BEEN
PARDONED ONCE.
NOT GOING TO GET A PARDON FROM
THIS PRESIDENT.
AND ALEX JONES.
THEY'RE TWO OF THE MOST
RIDICULOUS, CARTOONISH LIARS ON
THE FACE OF THE EARTH.
DO WE REALLY EXPECT THEM TO
COOPERATE THAT MUCH WITH THIS
INVESTIGATION OR ARE WE REALLY
GETTING TO WHAT HE WAS JUST
TALKING ABOUT, THESE LESSER
KNOWN INDIVIDUALS.
THEY MAY HOLD A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT'S GOING TO BE
VERY HELPFUL.
>> WELL, I THINK THE COMMITTEE
HAS TO ACT AS IF THEY CAN GET
EVERY ONCE THEY WANT.
THEY HAVE TO GO OUT AND TRY TO
INTERVIEW EVERYONE WHO HAS
RELEVANT INFORMATION AND
CLEARLY, ROGER STONE AND ALEX
JONES WOULD HAVE RELEVANT
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT WENT ON
ON JANUARY 6th.
THE QUESTION OF, FIRST OF ALL,
WILL THEY COOPERATE, AND SECOND
OF ALL, CAN THE COMMITTEE FORCE
THEM TO COOPERATE?
THOSE ARE OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS BUT THEY'RE SECONDARY
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT TO ASK FIRST,
ALL OF THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
SIGNIFICANT INFORMATION, THEY
WERE ISSUED SUBPOENAS, AND LET
E
'S SEE WHAT THEY DO.
SOME MAY COOPERATE.
SOME MAY NOT.
SOME MAY BE HELD IN CONTEMPT.
>> ASHA, STONE AND JONES ARE
WELL-KNOWN FIRE BRANDS, MUCH
LIKE BANNON.
I SUPPOSE THEY'RE GOING TO FIGHT
THESE SUBPOENAS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, JIM, I MEAN THESE ARE
NOT PEOPLE WHO HAVE ANY CLAIM OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
THOUGH THEY MAY WELL TRY TO
FIGHT IT.
AS THE, YOU KNOW, REPORTING
NOTED, THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE
AND I THINK WE NEED TO SEE THE
BIGGER CONTEXT IN WHICH THIS IS
HAPPENING.
THE COMMITTEE HAS INTERVIEWED
OVER 150 WITNESSES, INCLUDING
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO STORMED
THE CAPITOL.
SO THEY ARE IN POSSESSION OF
INFORMATION THAT WILL
POTENTIALLY MAKE THE LINK
BETWEEN THE PLANNING AND
ORGANIZATION AND THE
INSTRUCTIONS THAT WERE GIVEN TO
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE.
SO IT'S NOT A FISHING
EXPEDITION.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE SPECIFIC
LINES OF INQUIRY AND I THINK
THIS REALLY RAISES THE STAKES
FOR THEM BECAUSE IT MEANS THAT
YOU KNOW, THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF WIGGLE ROOM TO LIE AND WE
KNOW ROGER STONE WAS PREVIOUSLY
INDICTED IN THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION FOR LYING TO
CONGRESS AND SO I THINK THAT
THEY ARE POTENTIALLY IN THE
CROSS HAIRS OF YOU KNOW, SOME
VERY SPECIFIC INFORMATION THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS LOOKING FOR.
>> AND JEFFREY, IF I CAN JUST
POINT OUT, THE KEY ISSUE IN THIS
ENTIRE INVESTIGATION IS
ESTABLISHING WHAT TIE, IF ANY,
BETWEEN THE RALLY ON THE
ELLIPSE, WHICH WAS A, A PUBLIC
RALLY THAT IS PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
NOTHING WRONG WITH DONALD TRUMP
PROTESTING ABOUT WHAT HE SAW
FALSELY AS A CORRUPT ELECTION.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH THE
RALLY.
THE ISSUE IS WHAT IS THE
CONNECTION OF ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE INVOLVED IN THAT RALLY IN
THE RIOT, THE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
THAT FOLLOWED.
THAT'S THE CENTRAL QUESTION AND
THAT'S WHAT THE COMMITTEE IS
LOOKING AT.
>> ONE OF THE KEY QUESTIONS IS
WHETHER ALL THOSE FOLKS WERE
BROUGHT TO THE RALLY WITH THE
PURPOSE, YOU KNOW, INVOLVED IN
THE PLANNING AND ALL THIS, TO
THEN SEND THEM OFF TO THE
CAPITOL SO THEY COULD DISRUPT
THE CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS OF
COUNTING THOSE ELECTORAL VOTES
OFFICIALLY AND MAKING JOE BIDEN
THE NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> YEAH, AND WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW, THERE'S ONE LINK
THERE AS THE REPORTER NOTED,
ROGER STONE HAD THE OATH KEEPERS
AS HIS SECURITY AND ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WAS, HAS ALREADY BEEN
INDICTED FOR CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
AT THE CAPITOL.
SO I THINK THAT IT'S LIKELY THAT
ROGER STONE AND ALEX JONES ARE
AT LEAST UNDER, YOU KNOW, SOME
SCRUTINY BY THE FBI FOR THEIR
INVOLVEMENT OR CONNECTIONS TO
WHAT HAPPENED AT THE CAPITOL AND
HERE'S WHERE I THINK THERE IS A
POTENTIAL LAND MINE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE IS THAT IF THESE
PEOPLE DO SHOW UP AND THEY TRY
TO CLAIM THE FIFTH ON CERTAIN
LINES OF QUESTIONING OR SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS, THE TEMPTATION MIGHT
BE TO OFFER THEM CONGRESSIONAL
IMMUNITY TO TESTIFY AND I KNOW
JEFFREY WILL KNOW THIS BECAUSE
HE WAS INVOLVED WITH IRAN
CONTRA.
THAT CAN CAUSE POTENTIAL
PROBLEMS FOR CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS LATER ON.
IN IRAN CONTRA, THEY WERE THROWN
OUT BECAUSE OF CONGRESSIONAL
IMMUNITY.
SO I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT THE COMMITTEE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO REALLY BE CAREFUL ABOUT,
NEGOTIATE WITH DOJ AND MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T MESS THAT UP.
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO ASK YOU
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT.
YOU HAVE INTERVIEWED ROGER STONE
AND I'M JUST WONDERING BASED ON
YOUR DEALINGS WITH HIM, HE DEALS
WITH A LOT OF REPORTERS AROUND
WASHINGTON.
BUT BASED ON YOUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH HIM, HOW LIKELY IS HE TO BE
HELPFUL OR COOPERATIVE?
HOW DO YOU THINK HE'S GOING TO
RESPOND?
>> I THINK HE WILL MAKE EVERY
LEGAL EFFORT TO AVOID
TESTIFYING.
I DON'T THINK HE IS GOING TO
COURT AN INDICTMENT THE WAY
STEVE BANNON WILL, BUT I THINK
HE WILL, HE WILL MAKE EVERY
EFFORT TO AVOID TESTIFYING AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT AS ASHA DID, THERE IS A
SIMPLE WAY TO AVOID TESTIFYING,
WHICH IS TAKE THE FIFTH.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE, THEY'RE
BEHAVIOR IS UNDER INVESTIGATION
AT LEAST IN SOME BROAD SENSE BY
THE FBI.
THEY CERTAINLY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
TAKE THE FIFTH AND THAT --
>> THAT'S THE THING I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IN THIS WHOLE THING,
JEFFREY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
DON'T GO UP THERE AND DO THAT.
IS IT JUST TO DRAG THIS OUT AND
TO THROW A MONKEY WRENCH INTO
IT?
>> I THINK THAT'S PART OF IT.
I THINK THEY ALSO WANT TO
VINDICATE FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S CLAIM OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, WHICH REQUIRES
LITIGATING THAT ISSUE BEFORE
CONGRESS.
BUT YOU KNOW, ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO TAKE
THE FIFTH AND THAT WILL PUT THE
COMMITTEE IN A VERY DIFFICUL